have you and your family sat down and
discussed what your emergency plan is
you know in the event of an earthquake
fire a natural disaster we caught up
with katie belfie
she was the lead attorney for fema
during hurricane sandy way i like to
teach emergency preparedness and
readiness and resilience
is that you're never going to be
prepared for every specific emergency
what matters is that you have a strong
foundation and an understanding of the
basics
belfy owns a consulting business works
with companies colleges
cities on preparedness and how to
respond to emergencies
and after working with them for quite
some time she realized without resilient
individuals
these organizations didn't stand a
chance she since expanded her efforts to
individuals and families
when you start down this road for
yourself you can start to identify
things that might classify as
emergencies for your family that
wouldn't for somebody else
say you have an elderly family member
who's living with you who falls when
they're home alone
that's an emergency that you would want
to address
she has an ebook that interests
introduces you to the basics of
emergency preparedness
she adds the global pandemic was the
perfect illustration for all of us that
federal resources are being stretched to
a level
never imagined and that the more we
cultivate resilience on an individual
level
the more we'll be able to help our
friends and families within our own
communities